now if you do go past all this and then
look beyond the genders even be on the
television presentation there is one
firm result of this reshuffle and that
it does seem as if the government is
taking a slightly more you were skeptics
we've said goodbye to Ken Clark the last
great story euro far we've said goodbye
to Dominic Grieve who am a lawyer who
was devoted his maiden speech to the
Convention of Human Rights because he
liked it so much and and you said we've
seen hello to Philip Hammond who is more
you're a skeptic than William Hague he's
now a foreign secretary so do you think
that perhaps I didn't where there is
intended to unintended consequence of
this reshuffle but we now have a far
more you were skeptical meant but I mean
the ECHR thing is definitely intended it
was it was always known that the one of
the blocks to come and doing anything
about the ECHR was the fact that Dominic
Grieve would basically Rizzo mean if
Cameron suggested for example leaving
the jurisdiction of the European Court
of Human Rights I'm when you say doing
everything it supposed to be clear we're
talking about em that Justice Secretary
Chris Grayling has got a bill of rights
which he believes will be a new thing
senior de Strasbourg and will repatriate
all of these powers I Dominic Grieve was
fighting him now priests gone out great
so it's having on the ECHR that is very
deliberate I mean that enables the
Tories to kind of announce that they
have sought out all the inverted commas
kind of human rights nonsense all that
kind of stuff you know the advocate
artist things they'll be able to deal
with all that I think on the Foreign
Office front I think it's slightly more
unintentional i think it was when
william hague was going they decided on
looking up slightly minimal reshuffle
was moving the minimum hassle was caused
by meaning hammond from defense to
foreign secretary but he is noticeably
more Euroskeptic than William Hague and
also he is not been prepared to simply
play ball with with numbers 10 and 11
and for various points he said things
that really displease the wrong gay
marriage for example although Hammond
didn't actually vote against it himself
he spoke out against the fact that it
was being pushed that it was being that
why was this up the agenda than and made
clear in
that he was also a leading voice in the
National Union Minister saying you know
he didn't want more defense your hearts
he's more years skeptic from William
Hague quiet oh because he is a publicly
said that if we don't get some central
powers back he would be in favor of
leaving the European Union right and
then I'm in the minority they are they
are going to kind of there there will be
kind of shock in European capitals when
they read what Hammond has said I think
I think there will be a moment of good
God it will be another I think that
European capitals they have a view of
the British European debate which
willing to be inaccurate in in in the
mid-1990s I i think what when they read
about Hammond they will realize just how
far the debate here is moved that you
can be a Tory cabinet minister who talks
about how they would vote to leave if
substantial powers don't come back and
still be appointed foreign secretary and
it not even be regarded as particularly
controversial I think this is Labour's
reaching to the reshuffle as well I'll
receive you you're the opposition party
on the day the government party
reshuffles its ranks it's very difficult
to get a word in edgeways but actually
that they've been pitching all sorts of
quotes from philip hammond where he's
talked about leaving the european union
and it's their chance to have a line to
take which they've been developing since
last night which is this is a lurch to
the right ones Britain leaving the EU
and it's dangerous Britain's position in
the world that sort of thing every Labor
backbencher who's been tweeting today
has been tweeting that line and
privately they've been given that line
as well so actually to be fair to the
Labour press machine which has had a few
negative briefings against it recently
this is a good sign for labor because
they've got something they can talk
and you think they've got a point well I
think it as James says it shows how far
the debaters moved in the Conservative
Party and if you think that that's a bad
thing then you probably might be quite
upset by Philip famines equipment if
your conservative backbencher that
you're probably quite relieved because
most conservative backbenchers did feel
that William Hague wasn't sufficiently
robust anymore I think the problem of a
lurch to the right songs in the labour
of pushing it and have beans and pretty
obvious right wing casualties of this of
this reshuffle Oh incredibly
hard-working grounded gave the Giants
but probably the two most tumors clearly
right wing members of the cabin and they
both gone so I mean it's going to be
hard to kind of persuade the hack pack
but this is some great large the right I
think one of the other things that's
happening that which is very revealing
like this rich off of this now when you
promote people from the 2010 intake you
tend to move even if you tend even if
you ideologically balanced across that
intake you're moving the party of this
bit to the right because the 2010 intake
is to the right orbit of its
predecessors in the Tory party and I
mean I mean that's one of the things
we're saying so mrs. just strange for
modernization of the Conservative Party
also means moving to the right and
becoming more your skeptic yeah well we
have seen other modernizes like Greg
Barker quit and say that they're
standing down as MPs and I think Greg
Barker departed on his own terms but I
think he may well have concluded that
there wasn't as much room for people I
came he wanted the Conservative Party to
hug Huskies yes usually party anymore
he's far more dreams and there was a
time where an absurd of the common
project Greg Brock was part of it yeah
and Cameron sound is quite
environmentalist and this is greg
Barker's departure might signal the D
greening of the Taurus I think he
certainly felt that after that the green
crap was taken out in the reshuffle that
there was a need for the green
conservatives to mount a fight back but
the fact that he's now leaving suggests
that he doesn't think that either he
doesn't think that fight back is
possible or that he can do that
back and he's also pursuing the clothes
you go smile role which is he is Cameron
is sacrificing one of his friends so he
can turn around to the rest of the
parliamentary party and say that I know
your channel I know you've lost your
Chum over here but I hansard lose my
Chum my Chum graco I begin if you know I
have nobody nobody knifed for the good
of party unity